here we are now you're worried this
question wasn't nice it is nice Tommy
what do you think of Republicans like
McCain and Lindsey Graham who ever do
president Trump's executive order
banning Muslim refugees that's a
reasonable question you know I'm all for
anybody standing in their truth I do
think that McCain and Graham are both
incredibly threatened by Donald Trump
and I think that their relevancy is
threatened so they're lashing out but
hey you know what we're okay and in
public and party we have a lot of voices
so it's good right and what do you think
they stand on LGBT rights I know where
Trump stands I think that he's an
incredibly pro-lgbt and those issues and
I think that because their boyfriend
what they're not I just think that was
Rick Wilson do you think it's likely
that Trump's base or a majority the
Republican Party will turn against him
great question
well look at if he doesn't manage to
deliver all these thousands of new coal
mining jobs and to turn the economy into
some magical 1950s fairy land
well maybe 1850s for some of his fans if
he doesn't manage to accomplish a big
economic lift for the folks that really
were strongly for him which are our
lower middle class working White's he's
going to have a lot of trouble holding
on to those folks if he doesn't show
actual results you can't just tweet and
[ __ ] your way out of it right I mean
he has done a lot of job boning with
corporations you know he would say I've
already saved jobs before I even got to
the White House I say jobs because you
know I also read that corporations are
scared of him
call me crazy call me crazy but there's
a big difference between actual job
creation and policies that make the
economy get get lit up and a [ __ ]
tornado and basically that's that's what
all these CEO meetings turn out to be of
the accounts and the stories about them
are he goes in and says I built a great
business did you build a great business
yes we're great businessman together
it's so nice and these are in the Oval
Office with me and again it's like
santen script mr. guys Chauncey Gardiner
yeah I like television and and it's
there's there's no there there
oh poor you listen to all this I got
Rick was a Republican yes well that's a
Republican join on your but I'm actually
a conservative too that's the difference
between me and Trump people when I love
the self-righteous conservative work the
Trump people let's Trump me we are all
hassel when you see it's all going nuts
you love it I mean a little bit I
comfort myself with that beautiful map
on November 8th and they use the popular
oh yeah yeah I don't want you luckily
that's not what our elections are pretty
son Jace's bother you this is bother you
how like the Republican Party like did a
180 unlike everything like overnight
like like you know executive orders when
Obama did them were the worst thing in
the world and now the government isn't
runs like this year does that bother you
like that sort of like immediate on a
bath hypocrisy I don't know most
presidents do that when they first come
in there's usually executive dollars are
not as much and not after saying it's
the worst thing in the world right
what's the worst thing in the world up
until I think a 20th
I think people one of the things that
Trump really ran on one of the things
people are really mad about with
Washington is this thing where every six
months people in both parties just start
saying the opposite of what they said
six months ago I mean you look at what's
happening with the Supreme Court right
now so yeah I mean I think that that's a
problem for both but is especially a
problem right now I mean like he says
conflicting stuff in a single day I mean
it's a single century I've seen him do
it in a set right which is a tallies but
I was yeah I remember when Republicans
were outraged when Barack Obama was
picking winners and losers in the
economy yeah and now we've got a
president who essentially blackmails
companies and in debates I think that's
I'm going to tweet me about you right if
you don't do what I want you know it's
it's it's a very different kind of
picking winners and losers but you know
President game show host is got a
certain [ __ ]
I'm not going to let them talk about it
like that Sami Sam do you think that
radical extremists in other religions
are white supremists pose a threat to
national security too sure yeah yeah
everybody never have said that there
weren't other problems or other bed
people you know I wrote a whole book on
what's wrong with Christianity and I
think that it's interesting that that's
so much more popular among the lot like
yes I'm bad it's being yeah it's like
they want it that we should get them
that thing that she I picked them so
we're just as bad it well there is there
is masochism which is which is
attractive to some people apparently
push there's just a probably there's the
understandable problem that we see this
through the lens of a beleaguered
minority when you think of what most
people think of Muslims they think of
non-white people who are in our society
a tiny minority and therefore they're
deserving and rightly so they're
deserving of kind of the double
protection of the white majority
thinking wait a minute my being a
bigoted [ __ ] here and and so that
that sort of self scrutiny is
appropriate but it's just you're not
following the plot here Islam is not a
race right Islam is a set of ideas yes
right which which is a religion and we
have it I have to be able to criticize
bad ideas but you know I just add
because that you know I was debating
rogelio neon Meet the Press and he goes
we're talking about this was right
before the the announcement of whether
or not the the policeman who shot
Michael Brown would be held accountable
and Giuliani said to me we shouldn't be
talking about that that's such a small
percentage police people killing black
people is such a small percentage and
the greatest percentage is black on
black crime and then I pointed you know
you point out well okay true 93 percent
of black people who were killed or
killed by black people but 84 percent of
white people who are killed are killed
by white people but by that logic if we
would say that if we look at the number
of people in America killed by terrorist
acts in the last ten years
doesn't total a hundred so at that case
they wouldn't be Mohammed it would be
Billy Bob who's a
problem two white people in terms of
their vulnerability that's apart from
the argument is to make I'm saying that
part of the logic that drives you can
talk about it well but there's some real
big difference is there my ability of
not seeking nuclear weapons that we are
elephant okay your SWAT for the Middle
East there aren't billy-bob terrorist
armies what I'm thinking there are
trying to stand that but I'm saying my
argument well but the false equivalence
is made by a person like a Giuliani who
would argue then that we can't have both
and that's my point also after September
of I've also suspended by by cell
official hobbies out of Saudi Arabia to
the tune of whatever it takes but no I'm
just I'm saying to the masses of people
of color who are victimized by white
supremacy I'm just saying that that's an
immediate concern for them as well I'm
not denying I understand legitimacy as a
broader concern I'm saying this is why
people are also tuned in on that and
that's often dismissed as orlimar yeah
but but you should double down on that
and realize that there's all these
non-white people in muslim-majority
countries who are victimized by
theocracy right so they're very it's the
Muslims who are suffering from terrorism
and direct them is everything else that
we even talked about very slow in Quebec
I mean a terrorist acts against Muslim
brothers and sisters and they are
different and not often there but most
people who are victims of that terror
are Muslims themselves we understand it
right and by the way until Donald Trump
became president
you know Islamophobia which is real we
never denied that true I mean there are
people who just don't like other people
from because they're different yeah
although I would argue it's a bad word
that we shouldn't use it is a propaganda
term that isn't this kind of a carrot
but it's also there's a component of it
that is also real ruin and actually
happens but you know until Donald Trump
came along there was the one in Texas
the mosque that was attacked in China
and in Quebec
it was mostly non-violent you know it
was yeah they're probably like horrible
things people say to people at the
supermarket at dirty looks or Facebook
but now it took him literally a week to
turn that violent right and it's going
to get worse yeah I mean he's just going
to make it worse I would bet you any
amount of money but boy you're not going
to turn out
well for us as far as what he's actually
trying to do which is keep us safer you
would agree with the President's speech
it's a president speaking it doesn't
matter that it's the president that you
know a lot of people 54% of the country
voted for somebody else to be president
that doesn't change the fact that the
president is speaking and so when the
president does things like call it a
Muslim ban and treat people like they're
the enemy right a whole big swath of
people it yeah it's gonna have a
horrible effect all right this is Fela
someone who nearly won an election as a
Democrat in a red state what do you hope
Democrats do differently in the next
election so my experience that has
always been that politics is not that
much different from just like being a
good person like say what you believe
and be honest with people really I know
it's hard to believe I love how my easy
huh it's not nice I mean in other words
and right you know I are a boy scout now
here's what I mean people hear the truth
so seldom in politics that is very
disarming so when you actually meet
Donald Trump not that he ever tells the
truth but he you gotta fight the others
for him unfiltered and he doesn't look
he doesn't sound like a politician and
he is in his way genuine I mean that's
not a good thing ear wave lies are
genuine but he is really who he is and
in so a brunch bag from Queens search
for me till my president thank you
absolutely absolutely we only get one
president so anyway for me I don't know
where to go from there just don't let
president Bannon hear you say that
oh then he likes it that way all right
all right
we're way late thank you very much
everybody
[Applause]